and welcome to avengers campus
[Music]
when you enter avengers campus it's a
whole new experience
you're going to walk into a brand new
place that we've never seen before this
is going to be a place where our heroes
have assembled together for
us my name is scott drake creative
executive for the marvel global
portfolio
the decades of stories that have
unfolded with these amazing characters
allow us to have a diverse tapestry of
characters brought to life
and for the first time ever you get to
engage right in the middle of these
stories
every attraction here at avengers campus
is really telling stories with familiar
characters but brand new stories that
we've never been a part of before
whether it's the local heroes the cosmic
heroes
or the global heroes we divided our land
into these macro themes
[Music]
we have portals and gateways and
doorways that
literally open for amazing extraordinary
heroes to walk through from the other
side
we're also going to get to train
alongside them and we're going to get to
see them do really cool things we've
never been able to see in person
i'm dan fields executive creative
director for disney live entertainment
at walt disney imagineering looming high
above the land is a towering citadel of
the guardians of the galaxy mission
breakout
a fan favorite attraction that opened a
disney california adventure
in 2017. tannelier tavonne aka the
collector
heard through the cosmic grapevine that
earth's mightiest heroes were creating a
new campus
where they and all of their unique
technology would be gathered so tavonne
brought his fortress to avengers campus
you can see how it disrupted the ground
all around it you're also not going to
want to miss guardians of the galaxy
awesome dance off with every story we
told
we knew there could be a translation
into the real world
and finally the beginning of that starts
with avengers campus
at walt disney imaginarian we create
places places
with experiences that bring people
together and create memories
every detail why it's there why it
matters to the larger story
all of us that have worked on it are
just excited to welcome you all here
to see it for yourself i'm here to talk
to you about the avenger initiative
there was an idea to bring together a
group of
remarkable people see if they could
become something more
see if they could work together when we
needed them to
to fight the battles that we never could
do we do this together
[Music]
if you step out that door you are an
adventure
[Music]
i would like to personally introduce you
to
the future when you enter avengers
campus
it's a whole new experience
we wanted things to feel spontaneous
spider-man starts flying
bad guys show up we can't plan for them
so we wanted that feeling as you walk
through the campus that you don't know
what's gonna happen
you don't know what hero you're going to
meet around the corner you don't know
what bad guys are going to come in and
try to wreak havoc it's exciting and
thrilling to kind of turn each corner
and see
what you might see for the first time
this is the building of the worldwide
engineering brigade
on here you're gonna get to see amazing
things we're gonna see spider-man and
wave we've never seen him live before
obviously we're gonna get to meet
spider-man like we want to but we're
gonna see him crawl up the side of a
wall
be on top of the building jump off a
building and soar 85 feet in the air
so here at the web open house you might
have met peter parker
and been introduced to one of his newest
inventions which is the spiderbot
but here at web suppliers you can
actually find your own spiderbot and
tactical upgrades that you can train and
play with
so it was really important for us to
create exclusive
product to avengers campus and it's all
from the voice of the kids of webb so
it's completely in story
what is the type of product that web
would want what would they create
you'll see in a lot of the t-shirts the
hats and even the pins
we have a completely different take on
it the exciting thing about working
at walt disney imagineering is every
project is completely
different i have really loved working on
avengers campus because it is such an
aspirational story and so the idea is
that we want to make sure that our
guests
feel empowered to be like the
superheroes
not just fans of the superheroes
years before any of us imagineers walked
into the land
we had study models 3d models virtual
models we were walking through these
spaces
and looking at all these iconic views
and making sure that from whatever
entrance you walked into the land
you had an iconic shot of the quinjet
looming over the avengers headquarters
as this visual anchor for all of us to
be inspired by
[Music]
and on the second and third levels
you're gonna get to see black widow
and black panther fight against some of
the coolest villains you'll ever see
well we get to see heroes walking all
around the lower level of the building
it is hero central it's important for us
to deliver
relatable and extraordinary characters
so you may see them flying overhead
or you may be able to see them walking
right past you you never know what's
going to happen here at avengers campus
this is the product of an extraordinary
collaboration that that leverages
overarching themes like heroism and
becoming part of something more
and and this allows us to step right
into the action that we've seen
unfold on the pages of the comics or
through dozens of films
and now it's our turn to finally be a
part of the story
amongst all these giants now that iron
man has arrived
i would say it's time for the largest
team of heroes
ever assembled to help us open avengers
[Music]
campus
now uh hold on has anybody seen
spider-man where's spider-man
spider-man you're needed at avengers
headquarters the ceremony is underway
[Music]
programmed for maximum
nice altitude spider-man according to my
calculations
you're only 30 seconds later heroes have
assembled
now that everybody's in place the time
has come to activate
avengers campus friday will you please
initialize the ark reactor
and power up avengers campus
processing data and initializing arc
reactor
all systems now online activating
avengers campus in
five four three
two one
[Music]
avengers campus is officially activated
we look forward
to you visiting and living out your own
heroic stories thank you everyone
[Applause]
you